ich habe keine politischen interessen
ich möchte kein kanzler werden ich muss
auch nix rücksicht nehmen sie
wahrscheinlich dass auch nicht außer
natürlich die partei aber das ist so
eine miss organist als ich komme wie
offene titanic vor wieder suchte
rettungsboot und das schiefgeht langsam
unter wir sehen wir sind wie hält aber
sind wir sind hier auf der die ozeane
und keiner macht nichts das ist im
februar nicht vorbei das wissen sie auch
und das wissen auch die politiker dass
das ganze noch spätestens bis april
mindestens gehen wird wenn ich eher
meiden
was haben wir noch wir haben doch die
schwerste zeit vor uns